new research could explain the growing
number of mumps cases among young adults
who thought childhood vaccines would
last forever scientists warn that the
shots may be wearing off for some age
groups the answer could be a third mum
shot when somebody turns 18 oh no a
mumps outbreak hit the campus of James
Madison University in Virginia this past
winter 19 students and 5 staff members
got 6 starting in January and this is
the latest in a series of mumps cases or
dr. David agus is here to explain hello
dr. agus so what does his study show cuz
most people think you get the mumps shot
I'm done so this is kind of a great
detective story to scientists at Harvard
notice an outbreak at Harvard two years
ago and they said why is it happening so
they started to look and say is it
because immunity is wearing out or is
the virus changing and the new data show
that immunity starts to wear out
starting about eight years twenty-five
percent will lose immunity by 17 years
half will lose immunity so another
booster shot remember the vaccine came
out in 1967 you know a number of cases
went down 99 percent 20 years later we
added a second vaccine to eliminate even
lower the number of cases now we need to
get to zero because it's bumping up to
several thousand a year happening why
are younger adults at higher risk we've
seen the outbreaks at college campuses
because until the late or the 60s people
got the mumps
and they have very strong immunity the
vaccine wasn't as strong as getting the
mumps so we're seeing it predominantly
the younger kids and kids you know are
living in close quarters together it's
spread by sputum so kids swap a lot of
stuff when they're in college and so we
see outbreaks on sports team in college
and so I mean you seeing these close
quarters
what remind people with mumps are again
mom chipmunk cheeks like killer virus
you have these chipmunk cheeks in about
10% of people you can have more serious
things it can affect hearing you can get
testicular swelling and inflammation and
Men that may lead to infertility and so
this virus we can eliminate with the
vaccine if the immunity is wearing off
in this case do we worry it might in
other things for which people are
immunized or is it just specifically
with moms
I mean you know vaccines are obviously
amazing but they need to be improved and
they ain't perfect yet you know we now
give elderly to flu shots during the
year if you're getting chemotherapy you
get a second flu shot also when the
shingles vaccine came out it was good
but now a much better one came out and
so we're actually giving that new one
even to people who had the old one so
vaccines are evolving and I think that's
important it's not a failure there are
tremendous successes but they're getting
even better so as parents are ready to
take their kids to college should they
be stopping at the doctor's office on
the way and giving them that third
vaccine not yet I mean so it's certainly
not the recommendation that my gut is it
will be based on this data the military
do a vaccine a third vaccine when you
get in and they have no cases a month
and so this data is really pushing that
maybe we need to revisit what's
happening if there's an outbreak on
campus anybody that had been exposed
gets a third vaccine and it dramatically
lowers your chance of getting it but I
my gut is the the recommendations will
change okay thank you for keeping this a
family-friendly show dr. agus thank you
my best